[Music]
in huge gift news oh my god I want it
it's in cap so it must be real that's
what I miss about Christmas was a kid is
that the gifts were bigger they're so
small you get a bike or something or
like that you get a toy set and it's
like big in the package you get a big
package but then you get older and
people give you DVDs or some [ __ ] and
it's like this is your card we'll give
you a DVD
don't [ __ ] be friends with it and
walk more that was me when DVDs were big
yeah my homework down you know what for
Christmas I'm gonna get you a big-ass
box and then you're gonna have to open
it and then it'll take me a little bit
hey I would I appreciate that though cuz
I got the joy out of the bottle is what
dope it's what I don't mind a small
present like this right here it's pretty
small this like a diamond down don't
even at the rabbis so real but you know
what I'm saying where you wanna pay me
you see a big box that's rapidly holy
[ __ ] that's there's a library submitted
by the Lord's sheets a billionaire
celebrates his wedding by plastering the
couple's picture on the side of a
building
yeah that's dumb and not sick Oh in our
ball and you could do whatever the
creeper it's like guess what y'all gotta
look at this [ __ ] I think if I was
balling I've hired those plans and draw
penises in this guy like although that's
really good how come nobody does that no
one that's ball has a sense of humor
that's what I think is there like a the
sizes Harry ones but all cartoon looking
way not to annalistic yah musk is pretty
funny with the fart sounds in the Tesla
yeah yeah he is awesome yeah I would
draw I would have them draw dicks and
then I would have him draw like hehe
after uh-huh
long yeah exactly yeah lol laughter you
know I actually saw a like a big
billboard of some somebody bought it
it's like happy birthday Jason and it
was just like like a picture with you
saying I'm like three friends that's
tight
you know my favorite billboards or real
estate advertisements because their
pictures are so funny huh they are funny
but the real estate advertisement yeah
dude for like it makes me not want to
buy a house from you don't tell Bart I'm
like why do they use their own faces
shoving their fat neck into a suit No so
I used to be a billboard in LA like for
like years I saw this billboard and it
said LeBron to LA like become a Laker
and I was like what the [ __ ] somebody's
just bought it billboards so like LeBron
doesn't live in LA
why that's sometimes you got a
drive-thru right but I think that
they're counting on him like cuz he's
he's also does entertainment things so
that kind of him being in town and like
driving and maybe seeing it or some [ __ ]
and then it [ __ ] happened so I'm like
what do I though do you think it was
because of the this was like years but
you think it was because of the
Billboard I did people talk about it on
Twitter and stuff like was it was it
just spread around I don't know how much
clamor there was I just know that I saw
that [ __ ] and I was like I can't believe
that work
all right by a billboard this story here
it is about this mega developer named
Harry Macklowe and he this story funny I
don't know
no it's M ACK like not met [ __ ]
leprechaun anyway so this dude he's
going through a really messy divorce he
his ex-wives like they were married for
58 years 50 years he is 82
he's an 82 year old tech developer know
like
man why did I think he was a tech mogul
mega developer is what I said I don't
know Wow
so here software developer or something
okay yeah okay
looks like he's response for the black
cube building apples glass cube that is
a mega developer yeah so he's a
billionaire and so he is now getting
married to
21:17
okay he went up in age no no he's 82 no
no no but then his wife always sorry
his wife was 58 or their marriage was
fearful yes okay I know ex-wife who's 80
years old they were married oh so he
left it for a young hussy yes six year
old man he's [ __ ] they got more mobility
man I'm sort of hurt don't sleep on a
six-year-old you've said it those
dangerous as young ones those dangerous
young six-year-olds yes so they so him
and his ex-wife are going through this
crazy divorce right in one of the
buildings that they were fighting over
in their divorce this is the building
that keep plastered I know I don't like
this anymore cuz it's my wife-to-be
Patricia and then this is the thing that
he plastered on she's 60 yeah she looks
good yeah amazing what happened here
what's going on with this thumb here
he's bubu stuck his thumb looks all
really like a crinkle fry loose Hebrews
is easy
she looks great he looks like he's like
he's like a building like creeping up
this is the way she looks like Dina
she's gonna do yeah yeah they look
really good she looks she looks 60 they
both really funny makes you age very
well yeah I don't know one poor person
that ages really well they all buildin
go to Walmart I'll [ __ ] rest my case
because in the blood infusion they got
their blood boys
is that what happened right they get
Cambodian blood I heard about this week
on Valley blood boys so what's the
Silicon Valley good it's like it's like
I don't know if it's a rumor if it was
actually real but it's like a lot of
tech people in Silicon Valley have been
known to like transfuse their blood with
somebody younger well we talked about it
all right
they actually then it works I want to do
weird [ __ ] like that
and all the money in the world yeah you
sure somebody's Dookie in your
intestines and you have the probiotic
that's really smart it's a real thing
too I would do that it's a [ __ ]
transplant it is interested I don't know
you may get ship and they go alright and
they stick it up your ass like that's
what I think cuz you don't want another
source no passionate donors really yeah
yeah I want to know the source I want to
know where it's coming from
let me show you the restaurants that
they frequent when you when you donate
your [ __ ] they let you drink a box of
grape juice we know all about eagerness
with sinning question how do you okay
this is totally off topic but have you
heard of the the theory that like our
gut biotics are actually like what
they're like actually what controls us
and our human bodies are just like the
measure survive there's a like robots
for like like our human bodies are like
the mech portion of it that is being
controlled by our guts so that's why we
have like gut feelings because like the
actual mind control comes from our
presence read the use of the brain the
brain is not for well it's cool it's so
it's a it's there's partial truth to it
the way that they're saying were so the
the truth to it is your gut biome
dictates it's kind of like the measuring
of your nutrient balance and your
hormonal balance and so if it's missing
a certain nutrient it will send that
signal up to your brain so that your
brain can actively go and do that yeah
and so that's the part where it controls
your behavior it's not so much like it's
like a puppet instead of eating huh
isn't it
you don't have enough iron or you're
upset it's naturally drawn to like a
certain thing in or makes you to do
certain things it's because of there is
a tie where your gut biome is trying to
fix itself so it makes you go and do
these things but it's not like puppet
hypnosis behavior the teenage Ninja
Turtle thing that had the grass yeah it
was like some flatter [ __ ] where I'm
like this is next-level [ __ ] yeah yeah a
lot of hormones they found out are
produced here yeah yeah I mean I wonder
how much that's like connected with like
Chi and stuff like that - mm-hmm because
that's where it's where she comes from
right like it comes from like here the
first would be the below the gut and
it's like a stralla G I think comes
which is right from your ass okay anyway
yeah so this thing was just like hell
okay where does remind me of like the
solar system mm-hmm I think there's it's
the North Star a lot to it all right
it's the North Star I'm glad you didn't
say the moon cuz I don't [ __ ] believe
in that [ __ ] and don't even bring it up
I think it's [ __ ] you think the moon
is [ __ ] I think that the moon isn't
this fake yeah oh not the moon landing
wow that's a lot of percent Sears I
think it's actually complete [ __ ] no
you're making me smile because you're
smiling video I think the moon is
[ __ ] horseshit explain then continue
to claim a few whoever is in green
screen is it a green skirt like this
guys I know that we see this thing in
this guy but I think that it's attached
to something else
welcome to changes in Sundays
I really like like government support
like NASA to take like flat-earthers
like that like the like the most chief
to space like you conduct don't give me
reasons me order to a TV show where I go
with the flat earthers to try to find
these pirates that'll make you go back
oh that's more dude okay I'm getting
good
like we go on his boy voyage to see like
the edge of the earth so we were talking
with earlier where you were like I saw
the Northern Lights and she said she saw
the Northern Lights and it made me
realize how people in the past could
think that like for was the god of
lightning and like this was all magic or
whatever mm-hmm I say that science has
ruined all this [ __ ] for the rest of us
because I want to believe in magic and
[ __ ] meet I wish that years the decades
ago all those fools like Galileo all
those guys got executed like they were
supposed to so that we could still have
magic because they had magic no you
don't well I don't know I mean it
there's a lot of magic out there still
because there are there's like there's
like a portion in space that is a
complete like like blackness there's
literally nothing there and there's
always crazy theories that come out of
it like possibly one of the theories and
like it I think it's a like a bonkers
theory but it's kind of interesting
where because everything is erased in
there they think that it's like a I that
has like slowly been growing erasing
bits of the the galaxy because there's
nothing there where there should be
something and it's not a black hole or
anything there's no good area of dark
matter right where there's nothing in
this corner I don't know dark matter
dark matter yeah it's it was just boy
expand void maybe it's flat universe and
that's the part where it ends
every time I watch space [ __ ] like that
I get this feeling of oh I'll never get
to find out I wish I knew I wish many
will be able to find out I'm banking on
like cyborg technology by the time we're
like 80 I want some strong legs I want
to do some of my hero jumps out of the
second floor building we're gonna be at
that age where it's just at the cusp and
we're like [ __ ] our [ __ ]
grandkids get all the good [ __ ] where
you can [ __ ] live forever and I'm
like damn dude I'm gonna be [ __ ] 60
when you can live forever watching the
news and they're gonna like just reveal
that like they're about to launch it and
they're gonna be like in 10 and then you
die at 3 seconds
boy I see this yeah they're like we just
found out the moon is [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I'm breaking news the movies a total
horseshit
how you die like a vampire
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]